vous êtes aussi élégant quand vous
dansez j'espère
il n'y a qu'une façon de le savoir
[Musique]
nous ne sommes pas si différents vous et
moi à jeunes
un coup de main une seconde
[Musique]
et vous c'est quoi votre boulot
l'espionnage vous pouvez me signer mon
livre démonstration
j'adore ce roman
[Musique]
pourquoi il s'intéresse à moi parce que
vous êtes sacrément doué pour prévoir
l'avenir
l'action de votre nouveau roman a
vraiment eu lieu et vous avez mis un
coup de pied dans une grosse fourmilière
j'ai
[Musique]
tout pris de la drogue je veux toutes
les équipes à leur trousse il faut
qu'elle écrive le nouveau chapitre
je déteste ce chat
[Musique]
il est temps que je vous dévoile qui est
vraiment
l'agent Arcueil
oh mais non oh mais non